Bonjour! C'est les vacances, enfin, et pour
beaucoup de personnes les vacances sont le
synonymes de...
-La mer...
Qu'on voit danser...
-Alors non, les chansons c'est à la fin et
c'est moi qui les fait...
-Dans le port de Massalia, y'a des marins
qui chantent.
-On va parler de la mer, quoi.
A l'annonce de ce sujet, peut-être que certains
d'entre vous se disent qu'ils voient pas vraiment
le lien avec l'histoire, à moins qu'on parte
dans la géologie, et que peut-être j'ai
basculé du côté géographe de la force.
La réponse est non, parce que la mer n'est
pas juste un espace sur lequel des personnes
circulent avec leurs petits bateaux mais a
aussi noué au fil des siècles un lien très
fort avec les sociétés terrestres, nous,
quoi, et que nos amis géographes appellent
la «maritimité».
La maritimité c'est donc l'ensemble des liens
entre la mer, et les humains, et c'est à
l'histoire de la maritimité qu'on va s'intéresser
aujourd'hui.
Pendant longtemps les humains ignorent la
nature de la mer, et c'est pour ça qu'ils
y imaginent tout et son contraire.
Durant l'Antiquité, les savants tels que
Platon pensent par exemple que le fond de
la mer est en communication avec les gouffres
terrestre.
On pense aussi que l'Atlantique est peu profond,
ce qui expliquerait la disparition de l'Atlantide
sous l'eau.
-Je connais cette théorie.
-A l'époque on connaît surtout la Méditerranée,
si on reste centrés sur l'Antiquité de chez
nous, et l'Atlantique comme les profondeurs
sont des espaces probablement infinis.
Méditerranée signifie d'ailleurs «mer
du milieu des terres», et elle est représentée
en tant que telle sur les cartes jusqu'au
XVe siècle.
Au MA on pense qu'il existe une mer primordiale
qui fait le tour de la terre et alimente toutes
les autres mers du monde, c'est pourquoi des
mers fermées comme la mer Caspienne mettent
du temps à être considérées comme des
mers.
-Elles le sont à partir du XIIIe siècle,
précisément.
-On ne sait pas trop non plus d'où vient
la salinité de l'eau: de la chaleur, de
l'érosion de montagnes de sel sous-marines,
et pourquoi est-ce que la mer ne déborde
pas, pourquoi elle n'est pas toujours de la
même couleur, et pourquoi les vagues...
-Par exemple pour Paul Diacre, qui vit au
VIIIe siècle, il existe un gouffre au large
de la Norvège qui absorbe les flots deux
fois par jour et les revomit ensuite, ce qui
explique les marées.
-Il existerait des gouffres semblables entre
l'île de Bretagne et la Gaule et un autre
sur les côtes de l'Adriatique, histoire de
se répartir le travail équitablement autour
du monde connu.
Pour d'autres ces marées sont dues aux astres,
aux vents, ou encore à la respiration du
monde.
Et c'est beau.
Pour ce qui est des limites de la mer, ça
reste une vaste question pendant tout le MA.
La carte Pisane de 1290 représente l'ensemble
de la Méditerranée, mais on connaît peu
le reste.
-De toute façon, nous n'avons pas à franchir
les colonnes d'Hercule.
-Les quoi?!
-Le détroit de Gibraltar.
Effectivement, on pense toujours au début
du Moyen Âge qu'au delà du détroit se trouve
l'océan Ténébreux et mystérieux, et même
après son franchissement jusqu'au XVe siècle
certains considèrent que l'archipel du Cap-Vert
marque la limite à ne pas franchir: une
colonne surgie des flots ornée d'une main
serait plantée aux abords des îles pour
faire office de Gandalf des mers.
Ne pas passer, tout ça.
Toujours au Moyen Âge, on pense que la mer
est remplie d’îles à la fois éternelles,
mythiques et dangereuses, qu’on a tendance
à situer dans chaque nouvelle île découverte:
aux Açores, aux Canaries… Cette croyance
est si forte qu’au XVe siècle une expédition
se met en place pour découvrir l’île mythique
d’Hy-Brasil.
En plus comme on connaît mal les longitudes
à cette époque, il peut arriver qu’une
même île soit reportée plusieurs fois sur
une carte sous des noms différents, ce qui
rend la mer encore plus bordélique et mystérieuse.
Ce n’est qu’à partir du XVe siècle qu’on
commence à envisager de parcourir les océans,
pour rejoindre l’Inde par exemple.
Grâce à ces voyages les cartes qu’on appelle
portullans à l’époque se multiplient,
et permettent de découvrir la géographie
du Pacifique, des mers australes, des côtes
américaines…
-Et puis si au passage on peut découvrir
l’Atlantide ou la cité engloutie d’Ys,
c’est génial!
-Oui, la logique s’acquiert pas à tous
les niveaux d’un coup.
Ce n’est qu’au XIXe siècle que des scientifiques
adoptent une approche vraiment naturaliste
pour étudier la mer, avec par exemple Benjamin
Franklin qui est le premier à dessiner une
carte du Gulf Stream.
Pour ce qui est du fond des mers, ils restent
longtemps encore plus obscurs que la surface.
-En même temps, c’est pas super éclairé.
-Dans l’Antiquité, on s’y intéresse
surtout parce qu’on veut éviter que les
bateaux s’échouent, et les seuls hommes
qui plongent le font en apnée pour pêcher
des perles ou des éponges.
-Il leur arrivait aussi d’attaquer leurs
ennemis par en dessous.
-A partir du XIIIe siècle on est capables
de mesurer le fond grâce à des plombs placés
au bout d’un fil, mais l’impact scientifique
reste faible, surtout qu’on va pas se mentir,
les hommes de l’époque s’en foutent un
peu.
Ce n’est qu’au XVIIIe siècle qu’apparaissent
les premières cartes du fond des mers, avec
Marsigli qui représente la profondeur du
golfe du Lion grâce à différentes courbes,
qu’on appelle des courbes isobathes.
Ici, on les retrouve pour la Manche par Philippe
Buache.
A la même époque on s’interroge sur la
nature des fonds, et la possibilité de trouver
des chaînes de montagnes au fond des mers.
Les seuls à aller vers les profondeurs à
cette époque sont les pêcheurs, qui posent
parfois des lignes à 1000m de fond et remontent
des poissons nouveaux mais auxquels les scientifiques
ne s’intéressent pas beaucoup.
Le naturaliste Edward Forbes émet même la
théorie de la zone azoïque, qui veut qu’aucune
vie marine n’existe au-delà de 300 brasse
s de fond.
Spoiler, c’est faux et il existait déjà
des preuves que non à son époque: en 1841,
le Galathea avait réussi à poser un filet
au fond de la fosse des Mariannes, à plus
de 9000m, et avait remonté des invertébrés.
Mais les théories même les plus absurdes
ont parfois la vie dure.
Tout s’accélère au XIXe siècle pour des
raisons pratiques: avec le développement
des télécommunications, on veut placer des
câbles dans l’océan Atlantique, et pour
ça il faut bien repérer ce qui se trouve
au fond et à quelle profondeur.
De grandes campagnes océaniques ont alors
lieu dans la 2e moitié du XIXe siècle, comme
celle du Challenger de 1872 à 1876.
Pour la première fois, on ne traverse plus
l’océan pour aller quelque part ou dans
un but économique mais pour l’océan lui-même.
Ces expéditions permettent de trouver de
la vie jusque plusieurs milliers de mètres
de profondeur, ce qui fout en l’air la théorie
de la zone azoïque.
Toutes ces expéditions permettent un grand
nombre de publications scientifiques et sont
prolongées au XXe siècle.
De nombreux artistes comme Jules Verne s’en
inspirent, et le public adore.
Et nous terminerons cette première partie
sur les quelques mots de Théodore Monod pour
définir les abysses:
-Il fait noir.
-Il fait froid.
-Il fait profond.
-Il fait faim.
C’est vrai que...
On a beaucoup parlé de la mer mais pas encore
de ce qui y vit, et pourtant l’imagination
humaine l’a peuplée de tout un tas de créatures
étranges au fil des siècles.
Dès l’Antiquité on pense que la mer est
le royaume de Poséidon, que les courants
sont provoqués par Charybde et Scylla et
que croiser des sirènes s’avère plutôt
dangereux.
-J’ai lu dans un vieux livre une histoire,
sur un certain Ulysse…
-Oui, on connaît.
Les sirènes sont des femmes dont le chant
entraîne les voyageurs vers les profondeurs,
mais il leur arrive aussi dans certaines versions
d’avertir les hommes des tempêtes.
Christophe Colomb déclare en avoir vu lors
de son voyage vers l’Amérique…
-Tu veux dire l’Asie?
-Elle a pas encore compris.
Mais il se dit aussi déçu par leur beauté,
et il est probable qu’il ait croisé des
lamantins, qui ne sont effectivement pas très
sexys.
Parmi les autres créatures imaginées, on
trouve des baleines dentues dévorant les
hommes, des rhinocéros marins, des chevaux
marins, des écrevisses géantes, des serpents
de mer, des poissons en habits de moine…
On retrouve ces créatures dans les atlas
et les livres de cosmographie à partir du
XIe et jusqu’au XVIIe siècle, où ils sont
classifiés comme n’importe quels autres
animaux.
Par exemple, le kraken est considéré comme
faisant partie de la faune de Suède.
Dans l’Ymago Mundi de Pierre d’Ailly,
au début du XVe siècle, on trouve une description
de serpents de mer si longs qu’ils peuvent
traverser l’océan et des crustacés de
la taille d’éléphants.
-L’une des caractéristiques des montres
marins: ils sont énormes.
-On croit aussi en l’existence de poissons-licorne,
ce qui au final n’est pas illogique du tout.
Parmi les créatures qui reviennent souvent,
on trouve le poulpe géant, rencontré en
mer ou échoué, et parfois même des seiches
géantes.
Ces poulpes sont souvent décrits comme les
créatures les plus meurtrières du monde
marin, et sont décrits par Jules Michelet
en des termes très Lovecraftiens: «Il
offre l’aspect étrange, ridicule, caricatural
(…) d'un fœtus cruel, furieux, mou, transparent
mais tendu, soufflant d'un souffle meurtrier».
De nombreux témoignages parlent de poulpes
ayant saisi les matelots par ses bras ou fait
couler un bateau.
Pour renforcer l’effet, ils aiment surtout
attaquer pendant les tempêtes.
Parmi les autres créatures bien meurtrières
se trouve la baleine.
Elle attaque les navires, parce qu’elle
aime tuer et parce que c’est son territoire,
non mais.
-Une autre croyance plutôt répandue du XIIe
au XVIIIe est celle des hommes marins.
Ils apparaissent surtout sur les côtes bretonnes,
et ce sont des sortes d’hommes-poissons
qui vivent en mer et avertissent les hommes
des tempêtes.
-De manière générale, la plupart des créatures
marines ont des hybrides, comme la sirène,
le sanglier de mer, ou même les serpents
de mer qui auraient d'après de nombreuses
et fiables observations une tête de cheval.
Un autre mythe très connu, même s'il ne
s'agit pas vraiment d'une créature, est celui
du Hollandais Volant et autres bateaux fantômes.
Depuis le VIe siècle, on pensait que les
morts étaient emportés par barque vers l'ouest
et qu'on pouvait parfois les croiser sur l'océan.
Pirates des Caraïbes 3
-Cette croyance est reprise dans les années
1840 à Dieppe où les habitants disent voir,
le jour des Morts, l'un des navires disparus
pendant l'année apparaître au bout de la
jetée.
-Si ça n'est pas un plagiat du Styx, je ne
sais pas ce que c'est.
-Mais t'es pas romaine, toi? Enfin, d'après
la légende, le Hollandais Volant serait un
navire du XVIIe siècle dont le capitaine
aurait mis 90 jours seulement à rejoindre
Amsterdam au lieu de 8 mois, car il aurait
passé un pacte avec le diable qui le condamnait
ensuite à errer sur les mers.
Il existe plusieurs versions, comme pour toutes
les légendes, mais méfiez vous si vous croisez
un navire avec un pavillon noir, ou même
si vous entendez des cris d'équipage surgir
de nulle part: le Hollandais Volant approche.
Les raisons pour lesquelles les marins racontaient
ce genre de choses peuvent être multiples:
déjà, ils confondent probablement ces créatures
avec des phoques, des lamantins, des baleines
ou dans le cadre d'observations de flammes,
des éruptions volcaniques au niveau des rifts.
Ensuite, il est probable que les marins aimaient
inventer ce genre d'histoires qui faisait
toujours plus classe que dire
«j'ai pêché pendant un mois, je me suis
bien fait chier».
Il est aussi possible que des créatures mythiques
aient parfois été inventées pour dissuader
un peuple d'aller se promener dans telle ou
telle mer.
Et pour ce qui est des récits qui reprenaient
ces mythes, ils se vendaient super bien:
on les retrouve dans la presse à partir du
XVIIIe siècle, dans les romans du XIXe chez
Jules Verne ou Victor Hugo, dans l'opéra
avec Wagner, et même dans les objets de décoration
de l'époque.
-Ils ont un succès monstre.
-Depuis le XXe siècle, les scientifiques
essaient de trouver des explications pour
ces mythes: les poissons des abysses sont
beaucoup mieux connus, et on est parvenus
à confirmer l'existence des vagues scélérates
qui revenaient aussi souvent dans les récits.
Pour ce qui est des bateaux fantôme, ils
pourraient être des mirages ou des épaves
à la dérive bien réelles.
«Mout fut hardi, moult fut courtois
Le premier qui fit une nef
Et se mit en mer sous le vent
Cherchant terre qu'il ne voyait
Et rivage qu'il ignorait».
Entre les rivages inconnus et les créatures
sous-marines, la mer fait peur pendant très
longtemps.
On prend la mer par nécessité, pour atteindre
la terre de l'autre côté, ou pour des intérêts
économiques, et pas par amour de l'océan.
Et si c'est le cas, ça dure rarement longtemps.
Dès l'Antiquité avec l'Odyssée, la mer
est hostile, meurtrière et dresse des obstacles
face aux marins qui n'ont pas choisi de faire
ce long voyage.
-Du coup au Moyen Âge, on associe la mer
à l'enfer, carrément.
Elle est froide, humide, et chaque fois qu'elle
apparaît dans la Bible c'est pour montrer
que Dieu est en colère.
Et le pire, c'est l'Atlantique: le soleil
s'y couche! On dirait la mort.
-Elle est aussi imprévisible, même si les
tempêtes sont plutôt bien acceptées au
Moyen Âge car on considère qu'il s'agit
d'une punition divine.
-Si on l'a méritée, ça va!
-Néanmoins, d'après le journal de Christophe
Colomb, les marins ne la ramènent pas trop
quand il s'agit de perdre la côte de vue.
On pense que franchir l'Atlantique pourrait
amener les navires vers un chaudron bouillant
à l'équateur, ou rendre la peau des marins
noire.
Une autre citation du XVIIe siècle dit «Être
sur un bateau, c'est être en prison avec
le risque d'être coulé».
Une autre raison pour laquelle la mer fait
peur, c'est qu'on ne peut pas y respirer,
et quiconque se noie en mer devient perdu,
anonyme et sans sépulture.
-Toujours dans l'Odyssée, Ulysse aurait préféré
mourir à Troie que finir noyé.
-Dans les récits de croisade, la tempête
est presque plus redoutée que la guerre parce
que mourir en mer est vu comme indigne d'un
chevalier.
On se demande si les noyés meurent vraiment,
s'ils sont les proies de monstres marins,
si leur âme est condamnée à errer en mer...
Et puis parfois, le danger en mer vient des
hommes, et je vous renvoie pour ça à mon
double-épisode sur la piraterie.
-L'auto-promo, ici!
-Oui, bon, ça va.
En plus, il ne faut pas oublier le mal de
mer, qu'on retrouve aussi beaucoup dans les
témoignages de marins et qui peut rendre
vraiment pas bien.
Genre incapable de bouger.
Et puis il y a le climat, les conditions de
vie à bord, les maladies, toutes ces joyeusetés
dont on reparlera plus tard et qui ne rendent
pas le voyage très agréable.
Pour toutes ces raisons, les récits comportant
un voyage en mer le décrivent souvent comme
une punition.
Par exemple, Le dit du vieux marin est une
balade de Samuel Coleridge, écrite en 1798,
dans laquelle un vieux marin est condamné
à errer de par le monde parce qu'il a tué
un albatros.
On retrouve cette idée plus tard chez Allan
Poe et Herman Melville, qui était lui-même
marin avant d'écrire Moby Dick.
Ce n'est qu'à la fin du XVIIIe siècle qu'on
commence à se dire que la mer, toute dangereuse
qu'elle est, est quand même pas si moche.
Surtout les tempêtes.
C'est dangereux, mais c'est beau, une tempête.
On parle alors d' «horreur exquise»,
et les peintures de tempête comme celles
de Turner deviennent trèèèès répandues.
Et les romans aussi, d'ailleurs.
La scène de tempête, c'est LE rebondissement
incontournable des récits de voyages.
-C'est soit une tempête, soit un vieux.
-Et malgré toutes les peurs que la mer suscite,
tous ces dangers qui sont autant de chances,
la mer attire.
Pas tout le monde, mais elle attire.
Alors comment l'expliquer?
On peut penser à une nécessité, déjà,qui
surpasse la peur, histoire de plomber l'ambiance
tout de suite.
On a vu que le risque de noyade était l'une
des raisons pour lesquelles la mer faisait
peur, et pourtant des centaines de réfugiés
traversent la Méditerranée de nos jours.
Il existe des marins qui disent avoir une
vocation, entendre l'appel de la mer, vouloir
sentir le vent et le danger...
Même si certains regrettent ensuite.
On a même l'exemple d'une jeune fille de
15 ans, Anne Pommerais, qui s'embarque déguisée
en garçon en 1781 parce qu'elle voulait voir
la mer.
Elle prend alors le nom de Louis Renaud.
Renaud, en plus.
-C'est pas Anne qui prend la mer...
-Je ne comprends pas vos référence, c'est
exaspérant.
-Certains sont aussi plus curieux, non pas
de la mer mais des autres rivages qui se trouvent
derrière, suffisamment pour vouloir embarquer.
C'est le cas des grands navigateurs des XVIe
siècle, comme Magellan, ou un peu plus tard
la Pérouse, Bougainville, Kerguelen, Cook...
Leur équipage a probablement peur de partir
vers l'inconnu et d'affronter des bancs de
glace pour certaines expéditions australes,
mais au moins le chef de l'expédition est
motivé et ça peut suffire à motiver les
autres.
-La déter.
-Pour d'autres, les raisons sont plutôt économiques.
Être marin ou pêcheur, ça paie pour la
famille restée derrière.
Tout simplement, et même si les marins sont
parmi les catégories les plus pauvres de
la population.
La troisième raison est qu'on veut faire
comme faisaient les parents: à la fin du
XVIIIe siècle, en Bretagne, 45% des marins
étaient fils de marins.
-Et puis certains ne veulent pas embarquer,
en fait.
Les embarquements forcés sont employés en
Angleterre à partir de la guerre de Cent
Ans, on appelle ça le système de la presse.
-Nous vous pressons d'embarquer.
-A coup de gourdin dans le nez.
-Effectivement, des press gang étaient lâchés
dans les quartiers maritimes armés de gourdins
et enrôlaient les passants, les déserteurs,
les gens de rivière...
Au XVIIe siècle ce système assure près
de 40% des enrôlements, mais les gens commencent
à râler et se rebeller contre les press
gang.
-Le système reste quand même en place jusque
1869.
-La France n'est pas beaucoup plus glorieuse
puisqu'elle met en place une conscription
obligatoire pour les communautés littorales
à partir de 1670, visant les marins de 18
à 55 ans, pour qu'ils servent dans les vaisseaux
royaux.
-Elle élargit même cette conscription aux
pêcheurs à pieds et aux gens de rivières,
ce qui fait que tu peux tranquillement pêcher
la moule un jour et te retrouver matelot de
guerre le lendemain.
-Ce système est remanié à la Révolution
mais persiste jusque 1965, où il fusionne
avec le service militaire classique.
Pour faire face à la pénurie de marins on
engage aussi des mousses très jeunes, l'âge
légal est douze ans mais ça peut descendre
jusqu'à 8.
Ou des étrangers, aussi, européens ou même
indiens, malais, chinois ou africains grâce
au développement du commerce international.
-Par contre pour s'entendre à bord, j'vous
raconte pas la galère.
-Qu'es-tu allée faire dans une galère?
Puisque cet épisode est déjà plus que long,
j'ai décidé de le couper en deux parties.
Le sujet de la mer est très riche, je m'en
suis rendue compte en le préparant et ça
explique en partie le temps que j'ai mis à
sortir cette vidéo.
-Pour vous teaser un peu, dans le prochain
épisode on parlera de la vie des marins,
mais aussi des relations entre les gens qui
vivent au bord de la mer et la mer, et enfin
des moyens par lesquels les marins se protégeaient
de tous les dangers qu'on a vus aujourd'hui.
-Une partie 2 palpitante, donc, que vous ne
voulez pas manquer, et pour rester dans le
sujet j'annonce que le prochain Gentes Dames
Badass qui sera probablement la prochaine
vidéo de la chaîne parlera d'une femme dans
un bateau.
Mystère.
A bientôt donc, les grandes vacances et le
tournage de Time Warp aidant je ne peux pas
vous dire quand le prochain épisode sortira
mais j'ai déjà hâte de le faire.
En attendant, vous pourrez suivre mes folles
vacances sur facebook ou twitter, me soutenir
sur Tipeee ou Utip, et aller à la mer.
Ou pas, d'ailleurs, faites comme vous voulez,
moi j'aime pas me baigner, ça gratte...